Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai une question
de Lily qui me demande :
« Quelle est la place des Autochtones
dans notre système politique? »
C'est une excellente question
puisque le monde
se demande souvent « mais comment
vous vous faites entendre par le provincial, le fédéral?
Comment est-ce que vous
faites respecter ou écouter vos droits? »
Dans l'esprit de
la Loi sur les Indiens,
ça devrait être le gouvernement fédéral
qui prendrait soin de nos droits, de nous,
des choses qui nous regardent.
On s'entend que ça n'a pas été le cas et
que présentement, il n'a pas été
un très bon père de famille puisqu'on
est encore sous la Loi sur les Indiens,
je parle pour les Indiens inscris.
Son rôle de protecteur ou de personne qui
regarde au bien-être des Premières Nations
a été très négligent ou même des fois
carrément dangereux, quand on pense
aux pensionnats à la rafle des années 60
et à d'autre d'autres pratiques qui ont été
très difficiles pour l'identité,
l'histoire, la langue, la culture
et même le bien-être moral
des Premières Nations.
Cependant, on a quand même des organismes
qui existent pour protéger nos droits,
pour nous défendre face
aux enjeux qui nous touchent et qui sont
particulièrement imposés
par les gouvernements.
Je pense à l'APNQL, qui est
l'Assemblée des Premières Nations
du Québec et du Labrador,
qui est une assemblée des chefs de chacune
des communautés qui vont promouvoir
le respect des droits, le respect
des ententes, qui va défendre nos droits
pour tout ce qui a un rapport à la vie
sur la réserve. Il y a d'autres organismes qui
existent aussi en milieu urbain. Je pense
au regroupement des centres d'amitié
autochtones au Québec et à travers
le Canada parce que l'APNQL
et le regroupement des centres d'amitié
autochtones, ce sont au niveau provincial,
mais ce sont des organismes qui existent
aussi au niveau national.
Alors ils vont promouvoir le droit
des communautés autochtones d'avoir des
soins qui sont culturellement sécurisants,
de pouvoir accéder justement à du logement,
d'avoir des cours de langue
même dans les milieux urbains.
Présentement, il en existe à Montréal, à Val-d'Or,
à Chicoutimi, à Sept-Îles.
Et ça aide vraiment les jeunes
et les familles qui sont hyper mobiles,
qui vont aller sur une communauté
pendant six mois, vont aller aux études
pendant un autre six mois, vont être tout
le temps un peu partout. Donc ça va
toucher à plusieurs niveaux de droits.
Autant le droit du citoyen normal
d'habiter à Montréal, d'avoir accès
à des services, autant ça va toucher le droit
d'un Indien inscrit sur une réserve d'avoir
accès à des services. Donc, nos paliers
de gouvernement qui existent dans
les réserves, qui existent dans les communautés
au niveau organisationnel, vont beaucoup
faire de la défense de droits auprès
des gouvernements fédéral et provincial.
Pour l'instant on n'a pas encore un palier
gouvernemental autochtone qui existe
au même niveau que le provincial
ou le fédéral pour parler uniquement
des enjeux autochtones. Qui sait, peut-être
que quand la Loi sur les Indiens va
être enlevée, quand toute l'idéologie
de la tutelle et que les territoires vont
être redonnés aux communautés,
qui sait si on ne va pas développer un système
politique autochtone qui nous ressemble?
Et ça, ça va être difficile, puisque
chaque communauté, chaque nation
a des fois des systèmes politiques qui sont
distincts les uns des autres. Et là, je
ne rentrerai même pas dans le fait que
de plus en plus de candidats autochtones
se présentent au niveau politique fédéral,
provincial, municipal, vont défendre
les droits des peuples autochtones en même
temps qu'ils vont défendre les droits
de citoyens québécois et canadiens.
C'est une nouvelle pratique. Il ne faut pas oublier
qu'autrefois, le fait de faire ce genre
d'implication politique enlevait
l'identité autochtone, enlevait le droit
même d'aller vivre dans ta réserve.
Donc, ce n'est pas des pratiques qui étaient
valorisées, mais de plus en plus des gens
s'identifient justement à cette pratique
et vont utiliser tous les outils qui
vont être en leur pouvoir pour pouvoir
défendre le droit
des peuples autochtones.
Merci beaucoup Lily de ta question.
C'est une question d'envergure.
J'espère avoir pu y répondre clairement
et d'avoir intéressée sur le sujet. N'hésitez pas
à nous envoyer des questions et n'hésitez
surtout pas à partager le vidéo.
Je vous souhaite
une belle semaine.